voici le point de départ du scandale du
médiator ce livre de la pneumologue
brestoise irène frachon sorti en mai
2010 un ouvrage aux révélations
explosives sur les effets secondaires de
l'antidiabétique utilisé aussi comme
coupe-faim
nous avons observé entre 2003 et 2009 au
chu de brest
une vingtaine de personnes très
sévèrement atteintes par l'exposition
enfin que nous avons relié à
l'exposition aux médicaments et parmi
ces personnes nous avons trois personnes
qui sont décédées ces résultats la
pneumologue les avait d'abord
communiquer à l' agence du médicament
en 2009 le médiator est alors
discrètement retiré de la vente
mais irène frachon veut rendre la sphère
publique dès la sortie de son livre les
laboratoires servier qui
commercialisaient le médiator réclame
devant la justice le retrait du sous
titre combien de morts cette mention
combien de morts ne correspond pas à une
réalité scientifique avéré en juin 2010
les laboratoires servier obtiennent gain
de cause
le sous titre est censuré mais cela
n'empêche pas le scandale d'éclater le
médiator prescrit pendant trente trois
ans aux diabétiques en surpoids
puis comme simple coupe-faim est un
médicament dangereux beaucoup de
victimes dénoncent les lenteurs de la
france qui a attendu 2009 pour interdire
ce médicament
le 16 novembre 2010 en conférence de
presse
l' agence du médicament reconnaît que le
médiator aurait causé au moins 500 décès
le nouveau ministre de la santé xavier
bertrand lance alors un appel solennel
tous ceux qui ont pris du médiator c'est
de prendre contact et de consulter leur
médecin leur médecin traitant pour y
voir plus clair le ministre missionne
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales
six semaines plus tard le 15 janvier
2011 le rapport tombe
le rapport est accablant conflits
d'intérêts des médecins et de plusieurs
directeur de l'afssaps
pendant trente trois ans aucun des
médecins experts de l'agencé n'a été en
mesure de conduire un raisonnement
pharmacologique clairvoyant pourtant le
médiator aurait dû être retiré du marché
dès 1999 par le laboratoire servier
pour la lanceuse d' alerte irène frachon
ses conclusions mettent en lumière la
puissance des lobbys pharmaceutiques sur
l' agence du médicament
le lobbying la pression le déni le
cynisme du laboratoire mis en cause dans
ce drame et qui osent encore prétendre
que nous il ya peut-être eu un ou deux
morts le scandale du médiator entraînera
une réforme profonde du système de santé
parmi les principales mesures la totale
transparence sur les conflits d'intérêts
entre médecins et laboratoires et le
financement de l' agence du médicament
par l'état et non plus par l'industrie
pharmaceutique
[Musique]